hey youtubers is Charlie as promised
this is going to be my Tyrion video I
talked about my top 10 predictions just
careful for spoilers for everything
that's happened on the series so far
there's a new round of the giveaway -
it's for the HBO now subscriptions all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so Tyrion is probably one of the
most interesting characters if not the
most interesting character in Game of
Thrones but I feel like people haven't
been talking about him as much the last
couple seasons just because last year
was all about the return of Jon Snow but
now Tyrion is back in his element he's
from Westeros and he's sort of like a
super version of Sam well someone who
reads a lot is very smart clever and can
do a lot of battle planning he serves a
lot of functions so things that Varys
would normally do tiering can also do
himself but the other big problem I
think is that George R Martin didn't
collaborate on any of the season six
scripts so tyrion lost a little bit of
his wit like if you think that area's
dialogue sounds amazing for the first
couple of seasons it's because they
ripped it right off of the page it's all
the words of George R Martin but in more
recent seasons because the stuff that we
saw from him in season six was mostly
winds of winter material and Martin
hasn't written that yet they don't have
that amazing George are Martin dialogue
to fall back on
so hopefully the extra time they took in
making this season makes up for that
because tyrion is going to be huge this
year so I just did this in a top 10
format so starting with number 10 his
hand of the Queen Tyrion is going to be
the one that takes the lead on campaign
strategy you see them in front of the
math table here where Daenerys looks
like she's planning her attacks Tyrians
hand is the one that knocks over the
line here and even though there are a
number of really smart people in
Daenerys a small council like Varys he's
very good at making big plans he's more
of an information person so he's the
kind of person who would bring all this
Intel to tyrion tyrion would decide what
to do with it and then advise Daenerys
on a course of action like based on
these troop movements that Varys advised
us about we need to hit these places in
like number nine Casterly Rock so
obviously that's a big part of the
trailer so he's going to be instrumental
in them taking it and he'll be very
conflicted about it as much as it seems
like he wants Circe's head on a pike in
the way they left things your joy will
turn to ashes in your mouth we'll come
back around to that - that's on my list
but Casterly Rock looks like it's one of
the big
action set-pieces of the season the
really cool thing about Tyrion is that
he knows that top to bottom every nook
and cranny better than anyone else
better than Jaime and Cersei because of
that story he told when he was a little
boy his father Tywin gave him the task
of fixing the plumbing this is a way to
get rid of him like go fix the plumbing
make sure the [ __ ] flows the way it's
supposed to and he did it admirably this
was when he was very young I think the
analogy that he made is that the crap
flowed like the gold from their
Lannister Mines so really fun imagery
but he knows it better than anyone else
so when you see all these unsullied
flooding in here he'll be the one to
have told them where to hit it how to
hit it with their troop strength is like
in where the weak points are so even
though there's going to be a lot of
really awesome battles this season when
it comes to Tyrion character that one
will be the most poignant taking his
home from Jaime and Cersei just
foreshadowing the best of family
reunions were the last Lannisters the
last ones who matter
number 8 though when it comes to forming
alliances he's going to be the one that
will help smooth things over with Jon
Snow
because he spent so much time with him
going up to the wall during season 1
they even felt a kinship maybe Jon Snow
didn't feel at batarians certainly felt
it because they're both the black sheep
of their family
very odd men out both in their family
and in society almost like nobody wants
them in the south so it'll be fun to see
their reunion again - and it seemed like
he respected Jon Snow so he's probably
heard the tales of him being resurrected
so he'll be the one to help him treat
with Daenerys because the way they're
shaping Daenerys at this season based on
the trailer footage is it she'll be that
much more headstrong sort of leaning
into Mad Queen the Mad King part of her
heritage without going full Mad queen
like Cersei
but number 7 is the bridge between the
north and Daenerys he'll also be the
voice of reason when it comes time to
deal with what's happening north of the
wall because Jon Snow has all these
concerns that's all he cares about
but Daenerys doesn't know anything about
that so it's not like Daenerys is going
to immediately believe anything that Jon
Snow tells her even if he says he's the
king of the north even if they find out
that he's half Targaryen that would be a
mind-blowing revelation but she really
relies on people like Tyrion for
information like that so if Tyrion says
that what Jon Snow is talking about
is legit then Daenerys would believe him
but there's been no evidence that she
has any idea of what's happening north
of the wall so that's just part of
Tyrion being the person who reads a lot
the person who stays in communication
with everyone via Varys that will help
smooth that out and provide a clear path
for what's going to be happening next
because there's so much stuff happening
in the South so many campaigns the plan
that any big Daenerys small council
plans for White Walkers seem like it's
going to be really deep in the season
number six he'll also be one of the
people to help mellow Sandra's head stay
attached to her body when Jon Snow and
Davos come to Dragonstone because even
though she left everything that's
happened between them since they left
dragons don't remember Melisandre
started out in season two on Dragonstone
Davos was there because he bent
Stannis's man ever since Robert's
rebellion but they left in ever since
then it has been downhill for team
Stannis until he ended up losing his
life Davos lost all of his children he
lost his surrogate daughter in Shireen
and he looks like he blames Melisandre
for all that for just egging Stannis on
with all this talk of azor Ahai so as
the voice of reason on Daenerys of small
Council he'll be the one to be like
please you know she has some information
that we need she might even have
information for how to cure surge auras
greyscale using the power of the red god
if you can bring Jon Snow back to life
then surely the red God can do something
about that he looks like he's been
quarantined or he's been captured by
enemies because he sticks his hand out
to sell here and it looks like it's
gotten way worse so number five just
like book Tyrion he'll also help
Daenerys learn more about her history
like her practical history this is where
the Targaryen family came from this is
what happened to them over time and
Dragon lore so he'll a teacher about
Dragonstone he'll help teach her about
the dragons themselves like I said he
and Samwell share a lot in common in
that they read a lot in fact Tyrion
spent a lot of time growing up reading
at the Citadel just learning things
during the books during the Aegon
chapters and a feast for crows he spends
a lot of time just casually reading
about dragons but it was way before the
events that we saw during season six so
most of the Tyrion stuff like I said was
winds of winter stuff that we'll read
about in the next book but number four
I'm actually really excited about this
when Daenerys finally makes landfall in
King's Landing he'll be one of the
people to try and help keep her from
completely scorching it from letting the
battle get that bad because they do want
to take King's Landing Daenerys wants
the Iron Throne but tyranny it doesn't
want to see everybody get murdered so if
things get worse and worse for both
sides Daenerys and Cersei they start to
go more crazy Tyrion will be the one to
try and step in and stop things from
escalating to pure wildfire but I do
think that King's Landing
Daenerys meeting with Cersei meeting
with everybody in the ruins of whatever
battles that they have is the best
possibility for Lannister reunion for
them to literally pay off that Tyrion
line from seasons ago where he said I
will hurt you for this I don't know how
yet but give me time a day will come
when you think yourself safe and happy
and suddenly your joy will turn to ashes
in your mouth and you'll know the debt
is paid
so as Lannisters always pay their debts
Tyrion will pay that debt when they
finally make it to King's Landing and
they're all standing in the same room
together the icing on the cake being the
Dragons burning buildings all over the
place and King's Landing
will cause a lot of ash to fly into the
air so Circe's joy will literally taste
like ash in her mouth the TV show likes
to do that where it pays off offhanded
phrases prophecies in literal and even
funny ways so like earlier when Jon Snow
goes to infiltrate the wildlings Samwell
has that quote where he says don't worry
Jon always comes back cut to the end of
season 5 he gets stabbed by everyone and
all the fandom is like is he coming back
is he coming back you just remember Sam
Wells quote don't worry
Jon always comes back and thus he came
back so just as that came to pass Cersei
will literally taste ash in her mouth
starting to get a little more fun number
three when Daenerys starts to make
really bad leadership decisions during
her campaign
Tyrion gets to be the one to call her on
it maybe we shouldn't roast all these
other soldiers this scene here with
drogon lighting up all the Lannister
soldiers looks like a parallel for the
field of fire during Aegon's conquest
he'd be the one to say maybe we don't
have to kill everybody we really just
need to get a few of the important
people the rest of them will bend the
knee when they sense the battle is lost
you don't have to kill everybody
number two speaking of dragons though
they will address Tyrion
affinity for dragons today nurses
dragons have already proven that they
trust him they'll address the three
heads of the Dragon prophecy I know
everybody wonders if Tyrion is one of
the heads of the Dragon which is really
just a larger part of the zora hive
prophecy that Rhaegar spoke to Daenerys
in one of her visions and then if he
doesn't physically actually get to ride
a dragon just because I think one of
them is going to die at some point in
the next two seasons Daenerys will at
least offer him the opportunity so
really my number one prediction and this
isn't so much season 7 as it is for the
series it'll be that he is one of the
last people left alive if you believe
the rogue one theory of Game of Thrones
no one makes that alive I do think that
a few people will actually make it out
alive
Tyrion being chief among them like think
about it this way if Jamie is going to
die and I definitely think that he will
Cersei is very obviously going to die at
some point - hopefully by Jamie's hand
then already Tyrion is left Lord of
Casterly Rock and who knows what
Daenerys is going to feel about the Iron
Throne after the war for the dawn if she
makes it through because it does feel
like she and Jon Snow are both tragic
characters so if anyone's going to go
down in flames
saving the world it would be those two
people well let me know in the comments
what are all your Tyrion predictions
what do you want to see him do during
season 7 he's going to be a very very
important character he's always been
important but I feel like it's going to
be even more prominent this season
because they're back in Westeros in
their main opposition are his brother
and sister so it's just so much more
poignant so what's going to happen next
is is a bunch of people got to visit the
set so a couple of you were asking me to
do videos for all the things that they
revealed there were just a couple
behind-the-scenes things but otherwise
leave all your requests for Game of
Thrones videos in the comments below
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner Tim Blackburn please private
message me so I can get your contact
details there was a new round in this
video I'll just announce the winner the
next time I post Game of Thrones
while you wait for everything click here
to learn all about how we might not see
season 8 till 2019 I know that sounds
like a bummer and you can click here for
all my other season 7 videos thank you
so much for watching let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight